you would think in the 30s and 40s it  was closer to slavery so the stats would  be worse than like people would be i  don't think so  uh  as racist as they were back then it's  just different ways like they're  discreet about it  it's very discreet  what's like discreet racism that is  say it is is really subtle things okay  and it  mostly like most of the time it will be  really sly okay and i won't say most of  the time but in certain settings it'll  be um sly  and  even gaslighting in a sense because say  oh pro i was treated this way no no you  weren't treated that way like i was  there with you but it's something that  you wouldn't notice because it was done  discreetly um  but how would you know it's like racism  versus someone just not liking you